i feel
tricked
at every turn
this will affect everybody this will
make chains collapse
if it's not doing already it will
there is not a single choice i could
have made that can stop this car crash
coming at me well i think i've gone
through stages well i've just cried
constantly
the government should get this material
off these buildings now and worry about
who pays later
to look at the grenfell tower today you
wouldn't know of the horror that took
place here
but four years ago this was the
aftermath of the worst fire in decades
and one which exposed systemic failures
in building safety
it's hard to believe that flammable
cladding including the kind that caused
this inferno is still fixed to homes
across britain
i first met karim masili a day after the
fire he was frantically searching for
his uncle hesham rahman who he later
discovered had died on the top floor of
the tower
four and a half years later he's in
despair at how little has been done to
make homes safe grenfell uncovered this
national building crisis grenfell was no
freak accident i've said this before and
another grenfell is
it's just a matter of time we can't have
justice until
this element of grenfell is sorted
it's been more than four years since the
grenfell tower fire shocked the nation
and the government vowed never again but
there are still high-rise buildings up
and down the country covered in
dangerous cladding and it's unclear
exactly how many buildings there are
which begs the question if you don't
know how big the problem is how do you
begin to try and solve it
[Music]
a month after grenfell sophie bishner
got the keys to her first property a
flat in a high-rise tower in the heart
of stevenage
but her dream home soon turned into a
nightmare
we have
potentially flammable insulation
missing fire breaks
non-acm cladding that needs to be
replaced
and the cost to fix this is 15 million
pounds in law landlords can pass this
cost on through general maintenance so
split between each leaseholder means
sophie's bill is 208 000 pounds for me
thinking about moving on like starting a
family getting married
even changing jobs you think like you've
got this huge cost on top of you and
i found it really hard like
relying on my family to help and my
partner because
if i go bankrupt what happens to them
what happens what's the implications to
my family and to my partner
um
and yeah just it's completely put my
life on hold really um i also
had to see my gp and been diagnosed with
anxiety and depression this year so it's
been a real struggle
one shared by hundreds of thousands of
leaseholders up and down the country
desperate and trapped in flats they
can't sell with spiraling costs they
can't control
the government has allocated 5.1 billion
pounds to remove dangerous cladding on
buildings above 18 meters but the true
cost of repair is estimated to be closer
to 15 billion and this doesn't extend to
buildings under 18 meters or take into
account any other costs apart from
cladding like missing fire breaks or
flammable insulation
hi ash
i went to essex to meet ash wines and
his young family the building they live
in is below the 80 meter cut off but
needs lots of work to make it safe
enough to sell these are the timber
balconies we don't actually own one of
these
but as you can see all the flats this
side on the car park have them and they
go all the way up to the fifth floor
there's also flammable cladding and
problems with the insulation the
government has done a u-turn on previous
advice and now said that buildings of
this height don't need to get cladding
and other safety defects fixed but in
reality these words aren't enough to
reassure lenders
all right which ones which always get
this wrong guy
is that you two years ago ash and his
partner zoe had found their forever home
but because of the failures with the
building they couldn't sell this one bed
flat so the family of five are stuck
here for who knows how long
and worse still zoe bought the flat as
part of a shared ownership scheme
meaning she has a 30 stake but is liable
for the full cost of remediation
they're trying to put the genie back in
the bottle after they release it it's
just not possible to do they've
highlighted just how unsafe all these
buildings are
the buildings are failing these
instructions left right and center and
the government have probably realized
actually this is a bigger problem we've
initially thought it was and you know
actually don't need the form and it's a
bit too late a lot of lenders actually
know now that insurance companies you
know up in insurance premiums they know
these buildings are unsafe and they're
not just going to pretend that they're
fine
this young couple don't know yet how
much they'll have to pay but they're
nervous
we're having to research what will
happen to us if we go back you know if
we go bankrupt that we're having to
consider that as a possibility that's
where we're at and it's
yeah
sorry
bankruptcy is an immediate reality
facing thousands of leaseholders who say
help from the government is lacking
since the grenfell fire in 2017 there's
been a quick succession of housing
secretaries four in fact the latest in
line michael gove has said he will try
his best the easy people to sting
are the leaseholders i think is wrong
now it may well be that i have to come
back to this committee or back to the
house of commons and say look i've tried
my very very best and i've failed but i
just don't think as a starting point
that we should be asking people who
exactly as you say mary through no fault
of their own have been landed with these
bills to pay the bills
on the scale that's been envisaged
but as yet there's been no alternative
plan put forward by the government and
already a caveat that it might fail
building safety expert matt hodges long
believes the government has failed to
grasp how serious the situation is
this could undermine the whole housing
market you know this is typically
most of the residents within um flats
are living in cities or large towns
quite often they're first first-time
buyers or they might be at the other end
of the
age range where they've moved down for
retirement to release some equity so
ultimately
we the whole market is now stuck because
these
flats can't sell and effectively a
stagnation of the property market so
this will affect everybody this will
make chains collapse
if it's not doing already it will
and so i think everybody
will be impacted in some way
by this crisis
this is obviously your building 17.7
metres in leeds 44 year old rachel
loftus is getting desperate
one building gets treated one way
another building gets treated a
different way
she was awarded an mbe for her work
protecting others during the pandemic
but her future looks bleak
the building next to hers is getting its
flammable cladding removed but she
doesn't know when work might begin to
make her building safe it also has
cladding which needs to come off but at
17.7 metres high it's unclear if it will
qualify for funding
it has other safety problems too which
has meant she's had to fork out 12 000
pounds for a fire patrol and seen her
insurance premiums jump from 300 to 1800
pounds all this before she tackles her
main bill estimated to be 112 000 pounds
i don't even own this building i own the
apartment that sits inside this building
and the idea that i could you know my
whole financial future could be ruined
because of that just just seems it it's
still astounding and astonishing i still
can't really believe that it could
happen um but it's happening i'm seeing
you know i'm seeing this happen with
neighbours and people um you know living
just across the dark if i had to choose
bankruptcy
i just think you know i've worked my
whole life i work hard i'm really proud
of the work i do
um and the idea that that would have to
stop for something that's
sorry not in my control is it just if
that breaks me a bit actually
sorry
we asked the housing secretary michael
gove who works inside this building to
talk to us about the issues raised in
our report but he refused this at a time
when thousands of leaseholders are at
breaking point and they are growing
calls for the government to make
building regulations stronger and more
prescriptive
in 2009 the government had the chance to
do this a fire ripped through lakita
house in london and killed six people
it highlighted failures in building
safety but recommendations were not put
in place
this inaction will now come under
scrutiny during module six of the
official inquiry into the grenfell fire
planning expert jonathan evans has been
demanding change for years
in module six i think it will become
very very obvious that actually the
regulations the guidance the knowledge
of the lfb about
the safety of cladding systems after
lachlan shepherd's bush they knew for at
least five years that there was a
serious problem in the country of
external wall fires so hopefully the
people in the treasury will sit there
and think actually this is on us we need
to step in we can't as we can't expect
the nation and the residents and the
innocent people that are sitting facing
crippling bills now to actually pay for
the mistakes which frankly originated
within government
a sentiment which is gaining ground
ultimately all of this leads to
government they they own the regulatory
systems they've failed we've seen that
with grenfell we saw that with la canal
house before it and we've seen it since
so the government need to step up and
take ownership of this crisis they need
a firm hand on the tiller
and they need to manage this as a real
crisis
and until they do everyone impacted by
it is stuck including grenfell's
bereaved families who can't rest until
all homes are safe
sorry
i don't usually get emotional
i'm just fed up now
just you know
just fed
up i feel
i feel trapped
we feel trapped
because
just can't
move on with our lives
i just want it to be over you know
and for it to be over karim needs to see
criminal charges and changes to building
regulations so the lasting legacy of the
72 lives taken at grenfell is a positive
one
charlotte lomas sky news